AND THEN THEY HAD THE LONGF TO
SAVE BY DEMERS
REBOUND, ANDS CALL, SHOOT IT, S
RIEMER
PENALTY TOTO ON A BEAUTIFUL
PASSING PLAY ALL-AROUND BY THEK
AGAIN IN THE OFFENSIVE ZONE.
WE'LL SEEN IE GOING TO GET THE
GOAL IT, BUT I
CHANA BREAK, A
BOUNCE GOES THE SHARKS WAY AND
HUGHES MAYBE GOT A BREAK IN THE
FIRST PERIOD WITH A GOOD BOUNCE
KYLE BURROUGHS FINDS AN OPENING
AND THE CANUCKS GET IT BACK.
IT'S 3-1 NET THE VANCOUVER
CA
SHOT TO THE NET.
AND GADJOVICH JUST COULDN'T GET
TO THAT.ES
TIMO MEIER, A POWER PLAY GOAL
AND IT'S 3-2 BUT HE
FINDS ITR SCOOOORE!
TIMO MEIER ON THE POWER PLAY,
AGAIN!
AND IT'S 3-3ASE, BEAUTIFULIPPED
HIS STICK, PUCK BACK TO HIM, HDY
SCORE!
CONOR GARLAND.
AND IT'S 4-3, VANCOUVER.THING
BUT THE NET TO LOOK AT UP AND
OVER THE BODY OF THEN TIME
MEIER IN FRONTNET.
NOW TWO-ON-ONE
MILLER TO MOTTE.
>> Randy: HERE'S THE CLOCK
THERE WAS TIME LEFT.
IT'S ATHE.
S START OVERTIME
WITH THE PUCK AND RE